fallout from the Texas shooting
Democrats are out over their skis again
plus some new information on the
identity of the shooter and the man who
took him down a Real American Hero I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
all right so many things to talk about
today and I am looking forward to things
I like today because there's a fun
things I like in fact it's so much fun
that I actually didn't want to do the
show today I just wanted to be on
Twitter hash tagging accurate movie
summaries but we'll get to that in a
little while because some of these are
really funny but before we get to any of
that and I really do want to talk at
length about the hero who shot the Texas
massacre guy the the the evil shooter
who walked into a church and murdered 26
people including somewhere between 12
and 14 children that the guy who shot
him is an amazing story and really gives
the lie to a lot of democratic talking
points before we get to any of that
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at MVM T so do you see
this magnificent watch it is indeed
magnificent this watch it's just
fantastic I own two M VMT watches
they're both great I bought one for my
wife I bought one for my father
they are just excellent MVM T watches
are the best that you can get for a for
an inexpensive price holiday shopping
can be rough but MVM T watches are
perfect for this you can skip the crowds
you go directly to their website and
they start at just $95 at a department
store for a wash like this you're
looking at four to five hundred dollars
instead they market it directly online
and at such great prices MVM T watches
make great holiday gifts they've sold
over a million watches in over 160
countries you get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro again
that's MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro these
watches are nice enough that I've worn
one before Congress I wear them every
Sabbath they're really fantastic I again
have two of them I've one that is black
and I have one that is silver and I love
both of them they're really durable as
well MVM t.com / pure for 15% off you
with free shipping and free returns your
order from MDM T calm again terrific
terrific watches I just I love their
gear I also have some sunglasses that I
really like so MD comma / appear oh okay
so from begin today with the update on
all the information that you need to
know about this awful shooting in in
Texas so we now know we now know that
the reason this man had guns the reason
this piece of human
had guns is because the government
screwed it up so whenever you hear
people talking about why the government
needs more regulations just remember
this was a government screw-up in the
first place this man was legally
forbidden from owning or buying guns he
was legally forbidden from doing so
that's not stopping people like Ted Lou
Democratic congressman from California
from legitimately walking out on a
moment of silence for the victims in
Congress he walked out on it in order to
draw attention to gun control it's
really just grandstanding I went after
him on Twitter for it I asked him if he
made a habit of walking out on funerals
so that he could go to soup kitchens or
does he wait until after the funeral in
order to do the things that he thinks
are worthwhile well he wasn't you know
happy to hear that instead he said that
he was standing up for everyone because
we need more gun control this of course
has been the consistent call from
everyone on the left gun control gun
control gun control the government
failed here here is what we now know
according to media I okay we have our
answer in a statement released by the
air force today a spokesperson confirmed
that the shooter his criminal
convictions did not make their way into
the federal database according to the
Texas Tribune the Air Force has launched
a review of how the service handled the
criminal records of former airman devin
P Kelly following his 2012 domestic
violence conviction kelly was convicted
by a general court-martial on two
charges of domestic assault against his
wife and stepson under Article 128 of
the Uniform Code of Military Justice he
served 12 months in confinement at the
Naval consolidated brig Miramar in
California before being released with a
bad conduct discharge in 2014 he was
busted down to e1 federal law prohibit
him from buying or possessing firearms
after this conviction he had a gun
anyway why did he have a gun anyway
because initial information indicates
his domestic violence offense was not
entered into the national criminal
information center database by the
Holloman Air Force Base Office of
Special Investigations okay so this is
the fault of the Air Force that did not
enter the information into the computer
we've seen situations like this before I
believe that it was was it I think is
the the Charleston shooter who also was
forbidden from buying guns and there was
a screw-up in the background check just
saying there ought to be background
checks doesn't make the background
checks actually happen and now we know
that there are tons of red flags about
this again human piece of crap here are
some of the things we now know about
this guy
and again this is why it's it's so
foolish to suggest that the best
way to weed out mass shooters is by
confiscating guns from hundreds of
millions of Americans instead we ought
to be looking for red flags because
almost invariably the only exception I
can think of actually is the Las Vegas
shooter every one of these guys has a
bunch of red flags in their history so
here are just some of the red flags for
this for the shooter in in Texas in
Sutherland Springs number one he tried
to date underage girls and I mean really
underage according to the New York Post
when he was 18 he tried dating a 13 year
old and later reportedly suggested she
lived with him and his wife as a topless
maid and that 13 year old suggested that
Kelly essentially stalked her his court
martial for domestic violence was not
just him hitting his wife or hitting his
stepson he cracked the skull of his
infant stepson multiple times okay on
purpose according to court records he
assaulted his then wife she divorced him
he remarried he was arrested for animal
cruelty a few years back he was arrested
in Colorado Springs RV park for punching
a dog throwing it and dragging it he was
given probation after an hour-long
standoff with police results in his
arrest he beat the living crap out of a
dog and then he'd beat the living crap
out of your infant stepson and not only
don't you end up in jail for life for
these offenses you then can buy a gun
because the government screws it up so
there are a bunch of problems here the
first problem I would suggest is why are
you out on the street after you beat the
living crap out of the dog why are you
out on the street after you've fracture
repeatedly an infant steps on skull and
should be in jail for attempted murder
presumably instead he's out on the
street not only that the government
fails to report his criminal activity
said the laws that are on the books
don't work right he saw actual people
like David Frum saying yesterday I think
we should borrow all mentally ill people
and people with criminal convictions for
domestic violence promoting guns good
idea David that's been part of federal
law for the last 20 years okay it's
already been part of it it doesn't help
if the government can't enforce this is
the problem with how the government like
how the people on the left like to think
about gun control the government is big
and inefficient it lets things slip
through the cracks whether you're
talking 9/11 the JFK assassination or
this shooting
they let things slip through the cracks
they should have known about and then
later we say well if we just passed a
few more laws that would fix it making a
big and inefficient government bigger
and more inefficient is not the way to
stop these things the only way to stop
these things is to either give the
government fewer things to do and make
them better at it or presumably to allow
armed citizen
to walk around with guns and this is
where we get to the final thing here
this guy was threatening his
mother-in-law his mother-in-law went to
the church this was apparently sort of a
family dispute so he was on the outs
with his wife they were still married
but they were estranged and he had gone
his mother-in-law attended the church he
went there and shot up the shirt she was
able to buy four guns in the past four
years okay and the authorities are now
saying pretty clearly that this guy
should never have been allowed to buy a
gun here is a Texas official talking
about how this church shooting was
motivated by domestic violence
considerations there was a domestic
situation going on within this family
the suspects mother-in-law attended this
church we know that he had made
threatened threatening uh she had reset
threatening texts from him and and and
we can't go into details about that
domestic situation that is continuing to
be vetted and thoroughly investigated
but we want to get that out there that
this was not racially motivated there
was it wasn't over religious beliefs
there was a domestic situation going on
within the family and the in-laws okay
so we now see that there's a motive in
this case we also find out from this
officials again his name's Martin is
sorry Freeman Martin he's San Antonio
region director for the Texas Department
of Public Safety he also adds that there
is no way this person should have been
able to obtain a gun here's what he had
to say we can confirm that the sub
suspect did not have a license to carry
the suspect did have a non-commissioned
an orange private security license
similar to a security guard at a concert
type situation private security
background checks including fingerprints
and a criminal history checks with the
Texas Crime Information Center and
National Crime Information Center
databases were checked and he was clear
okay so this again is a government
failure and arts and we're told that the
solution here is government I'll tell
you there there is not sometimes there's
just not a solution okay sometimes this
is something that the left will say
about terrorist attacks and I think
there is some truth to it I think there
are there measures that we can take to
minimize the possibility but when you
are talking about crazy people who
obtain guns in violation of law already
passing more laws is not going to stop
that from occurring
and in fact the people on the left
Elizabeth Warren for example Elizabeth
Warren was out there tweeting about the
NRA this holy God the NRA the NRA is
paying people off first of all the NRA
is not paying people off there millions
of people who are members of the NRA
because they believe that their best
shot at defending their lives and is
what the founders believed too was
owning a firearm John Adams talked about
the fact that everyone in Massachusetts
was mandated mandated by law in colonial
times to own a gun for purposes of being
part of the state militia protecting
their lives in their liberty okay this
has always been part of the American
creed and I think it's a very good part
of the American creed Elizabeth Warren
however says the NRA is responsible you
see a bunch of people on the Left saying
things like the NRA just doesn't care if
there are terrorist attacks the NRA
doesn't care if there are mass shootings
the NRA is behind these things that it
benefits the NRA somehow for there to be
mass shootings well here is the lie for
it for that does this gives the light of
that the guy who shot and presumably
killed this this shooter this mass
shooter know that the mass shooter was
shot I guess three times twice he was
wounded and man who wounded him was this
man right here Stephen Willeford so
Stephen Willeford is a lifelong NRA
member Stephen Willeford is an NRA
instructor and here's Stephen Willer
Stephen Willeford represents everything
that the Left hates about American gun
ownership but here they have to pay
homage to him because he actually saved
lives I mean this guy could have gone
with his gun and shot up many more
places if Stephen Willeford hadn't
hopped in I mean this is an amazing
thing that happened in Texas that
wouldn't happen nearly anyplace else
there were there are two separate people
who came to running to the situation
carrying guns and then chased this guy
down with their truck knowing that not
only was he armed and dangerous he just
murdered dozens of people that's an
amazing amazing thing but here is the
the one of the heroes of the story
Stephen Willeford and and how it came
about that he that he shot this is this
evil piece of garbage on steven crowder
show every time i heard a shot i was
thinking that was assigned to someone
else right that shot was assigned he was
shooting at another person every time I
heard I stock fire and I didn't have
time to put shoes on oh he had first
shot for me as my head but
as I was behind the truck and using it
for cover okay and we exchanged fire and
he had the neighbor's car's windshield
he hit the neighbor's house and he got
into the vehicle and I fired a beginner
and he fired two more shots through his
side actually he shot fired two shots
through a side window first and it put
Otis the two distinct pistol shots
coming through the sides of the window
and I fired my our 15 again and it took
the window down it fell okay
and I took and I took another stop and
at this point I'm stupid where his head
would be okay and he ended up actually
shooting and wounding the eye twice once
in the leg and once in the body he was
using his own rifle right a rifle that
the left wants to ban the ar-15 he was
using his rifle to take down this guy
what would this could this guy taint his
guns illegally again for the ninth time
this guy obtained his guns illegally
what would have happened if he had the
guns and Stephen Willeford did not have
the guns and was not an NRA instructor
he continues again this is the type of
American that there are so many on the
hardcore left who they really dislike
this guy right he's a bitter clinger
clings to God and religion and guns
obviously right exactly the kind of
person that Barack Obama didn't like in
2008 here he is explaining why he's no
hero
and talking about God in a way that
makes a left very very uncomfortable I
was scared to death
I was I was scared for me and I was
scared for every one of them I was
scared for my own family that just lived
less than a block away Oh God
I'm no hero I am NOT I think my God my
Lord protected me and gave me the skills
to do what needed to be done
and I just wish I could have gotten
there faster but I didn't know hey for
all of the people for all the people on
the left you've been saying thoughts and
prayers are meaningless and that none of
this matters this is what thoughts and
prayers are are for okay thoughts and
prayers are for stealing people like
Stephen Willeford thoughts and prayers
it's it's a religious belief that you
have to cultivate your skills in order
so that you can defend others okay as
man says he's not a hero he is a hero he
says he was scared but being scared is
what makes him a hero right me he was
scared he ran out there barefoot loading
his gun while he was running toward the
toward the sound of the fire and he was
not the only person who did this by the
way he wasn't the only guy but the fact
that you know he's a deeply religious
person obviously the fact that the left
does not I'm seeing a lot of folks on
the Left today and and yeah it's not
everyone on the left obviously but I
think that I'm seeing a lot of folks on
the left today who are disparaging the
thoughts and prayers stuff and they're
also suggesting how could he be
religious this is such a it's such a
honestly teenage take on religion how
could he be religious when people in a
church just got shot and killed okay the
problem of theodicy the problem of how
does evil exist in a world where God has
Providence how does that work this has
been something that religious thinkers
have been thinking about for
legitimately thousands of years okay
this is nothing new and religious people
have come to the conclusion there are
certain things that we just don't
understand about God's action that
doesn't mean that God doesn't have a
plan and it also doesn't mean that I
don't have a duty and it's that duty
that godly Duty that drove Stephen
Willeford he is a hero he did own a gun
he needed to own the gun he was a member
of the NRA who's an NRA instructor okay
though I keep hearing the NRA is behind
these shootings the NRA likes these
shootings named for me now how many
members of the NRA have been responsible
for mass shootings the answer is zero
the whole purpose of the NRA is to arm
people like Stephen Williford not to arm
people like this piece-of-crap who shot
up the church and again the law barred
that guy from owning a gun but the left
wants is from the Watts who also bar
Stephen Williford from owning a gun how
would that have gone exactly I want to
give some some time to the the other
hero in the situation a guy named Johnny
Langer Dorf and and talk about
misconception in my own in a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at frame bridge so if you
are looking to frame family photos frame
bridge is the best place to do it we use
it in the Shapiro household what we do
is we go to frame bridge comm we upload
our photos from our computer directly
from our Instagram feed or if you have a
physical item we send it directly to
them and then they mail it back
framed ready to be put on the wall they
have an expert team that will custom
frame our item in days and you can
preview your photo online in any frame
style they'll deliver your finished
piece directly to you
or your loved ones along with a
handwritten gift note it makes fantastic
Christmas gift or Hanukkah gift or
Kwanzaa gets whatever holiday you you
are part of instead of the hundreds that
you would pay at a framing store for
custom framing their prices started at
39 bucks all shipping is free plus my
listeners will get 15% off their first
order at frame bridge comm promo code
Shapiro again that's frame bridge comm
promo code Shapiro and they offer
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it you're not 100 percent satisfied
they will make it right again frame
bridge calm and use promo code Shapiro
this is a unique gift that makes for a
terrific family gift again promo code
Shapiro at frame bridge comm get 15% off
your first order and the prices are
cheaper than the retail outlets anyway
so you'd want to go there anyway for
Enbridge comm promo code Shapiro okay so
the the other hero of this story is an
Emil angered or so what happened is that
Steven will offer charged out of his
house after being told by his daughter
there's some shooting going on at the
church he charged out of his house
barefoot with his gun trying to load his
magazine as he went pulled it out of his
gun safe because he keeps it safe like
most gun owners do he charged out and he
started shooting the shooter jumped in
his car I think was a truck and began
driving away and Williford flagged down
Johnny Langer Dorf and jumped in
language Orff's car and they started
chasing the guy remember these are
civilians chasing a bad guy I can
promise you in Los Angeles when there's
a bad guy civilians don't chase the bad
guy they wait for the cops to come in
Texas
can't live my entire life in LA the same
thing is true in Cambridge where I lived
for three years in Texas when there's a
bad guy people understand that they may
be the only the last dividing line
between that bad guy and bad thing
happening and bad things happening and
so they hop in their car and they follow
it's one of my favorite things there's a
movie called hell or high water which is
kind of a fun movie and it's one of my
favorite things in that film is that
there's a bank robbery and everyone at
the bank pulls out a gun and then they
all begin chasing down the bank robbers
it's one of my favorite things in the
film and that was true to life because
that's exactly what happened in southern
island Springs Texas here is here is
Johnny Langer Dorf talking a little bit
into I believe this his wife now talking
with Anderson Cooper about whether he
would have done this again if he knew
that the guy was armed and dangerous
it's not surprising at all he's a great
guy great
he's very courageous and super humble
about the whole situation and that's
just awesome it doesn't surprise me at
all that's the way that's just the way
he is yes
Jonnie knowing what you know now I mean
would you do the same thing over again I
would do it a hundred times over sir
okay so you know one of the things that
I was gonna say about misconceptions
look at this guy I mean he's got a neck
tattoo he doesn't look like he's
necessarily you know going to the Ivy
League colleges and it's very easy for
those of us who live on the coast so
well could somebody like Johnny Langer
Dorf neck tattoo and say oh what a hick
what a hick this is the kind of guy you
know it's not not everyone with a neck
tattoo is Johnny Lango Dorf but not
everyone without a neck tattoo is Johnny
language or if either and the fact is
this guy is the guy who was on the spot
and he did the right thing don't judge a
book by it's cover and that's a good
lesson to people like me who who
sometimes make judgments based on things
like this as well heroism comes in a lot
of different shapes and sizes but it
does share a belief system and that
belief system is that when when someone
has to stand between the evil and the
innocent you're the person who has to
stands up and do something okay and we
can treat government like it's God we
can pretend that government is capable
of protecting us against all evils it's
just not true it is just not the case
the government can protect us against
all evils and that's why an armed
populace is very often necessary to stop
this stuff and the Washington Post put
out an article yesterday with the
headline one thing mass shooters have in
common they're men with guns well yes in
a mass shooting situation you would
assume they have guns and you would
assume that criminals are typically men
but there's something they neglect okay
in a mass shooting situation the person
who typically stops the mass shooting is
also a man with a gun whether it's a
police officer or whether it is a
civilian as in this case and it is much
more likely than NRA member is going to
stop a mass shooting then that an NRA
member is going to perpetrate a mass
shooting despite what the left to it
would have you say well the media of
course don't care about any of this the
media don't want to hear any of this the
media simply want to talk a gun control
and if you don't believe in media bias
let me show you this clip now if
President Trump in South Korea so he's
in South Korea now and he was asked by
an NBC news reporter is he still in
Japan he's mu head in South Korea today
but he is he's he's asked by an NBC news
reporter about the situation in the
situation in Texas specifically she asks
whether he would apply his extreme
vetting of standards to gun control and
here's Trump's response which is correct
I guess he wasn't South Korea
after all you've talked about wanting to
put extreme betting on people trying to
come into the United States but I wonder
if you would consider extreme betting
for people trying to buy a gun well you
know you're bringing up a situation that
probably shouldn't be discussed too much
right now but it's okay if you feel that
that's an appropriate question even
though we're the part of South Korea if
you did what you're suggesting there
would have been no difference three days
ago and you might not have had that very
brave person who happened to have a gun
or a rifle in his truck go out and shoot
him and hit him and neutralize him and I
can only say this if he didn't have a
gun instead of having 26 dead he would
have had hundreds more dead and are you
considering any kind of gun control
policy can you look at the city with the
strongest gun laws in our nation in
Chicago and Chicago is a disaster if
this man didn't have a gun or a rifle
you'd be talking about a much worse
situation in the great state of Texas
Trump is of course right and this is why
so many people on the right like Trump
is because you know at least Trump is
and Hillary actually applies here
because if you imagine Hillary Clinton
in this situation she's pushing for
widespread gun confiscations in all
likelihood she's praised Australia's gun
buyback program and confiscation program
she's praised Canada's gun laws Hillary
Clinton would be saying something very
very different and then Donald Trump is
saying right here and what Trump is
saying is basically correct but the
point I want to make is this NBC News
reporter I mean if you look at her face
throughout this particular question the
scorn she has not only for president
Trump but for people who are gun owners
for for gun ownership for the right to
keep and bear arms which the founders
thought was so valuable it's it is it is
emanating from her the difference
between owning a gun and entering the
country is I have a right to own a gun
to protect my life and my family's life
I do not have a right to become a
citizen of the United States extreme
vetting is necessary for people coming
into the country because they don't have
a right to enter the United States
because we have to protect ourselves
that same decision to protect ourselves
undergirds our ability to own a gun and
use a gun in our own self-defense
okay it is the exact same reason the
reason you have extreme vetting with
regard to people entering the country is
the reason why you don't have extreme
vetting for American citizens who have
not committed a crime and once you own a
gun to protect themselves that doesn't
mean no vetting of course no one wants
to have criminals with guns of course no
one wants to have mentally ill people
with guns and Ted Cruz makes a really
good point here you know Ted Cruz is
specifically asked about you know people
who are violating the law by owning guns
and here's what senator Cruz has to say
this should have been stopped beforehand
under federal law it was illegal for
this individual to purchase a firearm he
had a conviction for a crime that's
punishable by more than a year in prison
and he had a conviction for multiple
domestic violence crimes both of those
it's already ineligible but several
things happen number one the Air Force
the Obama administration didn't report
those convictions to the NCIS database
that's an endemic problem it's a problem
with the federal government it's a
problem with the states and so when he
went in to buy the guns they ran the
background check and they didn't find it
because it wasn't in the database okay
and Cruz here is exactly right of course
now a lot of people been saying well you
know if we just had gun confiscations
like Australia then the number of mass
shootings would go down the problem is
this mass shootings are so statistically
uncommon I'm not saying they're uncommon
in the sense like colloquially they
never happened but they're statistically
uncommon as compared to other types of
murder and so there is no good comp in
terms of looking at a system where okay
there's a massive gun confiscation and
the number of mass shootings went down
and may have gone down from three to
zero right it wasn't like Australia had
mass shootings every five minutes
Australia had very few mass shootings
and now they have no no mass shootings
but their murder rate actually declines
at a lower rate than the u.s. murder
rate over the same period since their
gun confiscation the US has murder rate
decline faster even though more people
were purchasing guns not fewer people
okay before I go any further I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
blinken so if you're addicted to
information which I know you are since
you listen to this show you need to get
the bling cast app blankest makes sure
that you can get all of the information
from the latest popular books
non-fiction books you're constantly
increasing your knowledge level if
you've never read four books in one day
blanka's helps you do that because what
they do is they summarize all of these
books the main points of these books in
these 15-minute little packages they
like to call blinks 2,000 of the best
selling non-fiction books transformed
into these powerful packs that you can
read or listen to in just 15 minutes as
you know if you're listening to the show
you love information and so do I which
is why you can get books like why
nations still seek a 600 page book I've
actually read that book what do I
remember from it - I remember 15 minutes
of worth of material probably not but
when you get blink cast you get all the
same information that I probably spent
hours reading in just 15 minutes they
have books like crippled America and two
nations invisible they have books like
myth of a strong leader they have a lot
of pop science books which I really
enjoy a lot of history books that I
really enjoy it's it's used by three
million people it has over three million
users you should be one of them right
now blankets has a special offer just
for our audience go to blink it's calm
slash been right now and start your free
trial or get three months off your
yearly plan when you join today
that's blink is spelled bli n ke ist
blink cast comm slash Ben to start your
free trial or get three months off your
yearly plan again it's blink it's calm
slash Ben go ahead and check it out they
have all these popular books I've read a
lot of these books and I wish that I
read blink I done the blankets instead
of reading the full book in some of
these cases but a lot of my favorite
books Piatt things like the power of
habit and flow and drive all of these
books about sort of self betterment all
these things are available on blanket so
get that blink a snap and remember to
use that promo code that blink is calm /
Ben and you get that free trial or three
months off your yearly subscription okay
so the media response on this of course
has been egregious as I have mentioned
you saw the NBC response John lemon
whose show I enjoy hearing on he said
that we should stop with the thoughts
and prayers no more thoughts and prayers
and and this transitions us into another
topic about thought and prayer that I
want to discuss in just a second here's
here's lemon on thoughts and prayers
thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers thoughts and prayers don't get
me wrong prayers are important they
really are but can we just be honest for
a moment and this isn't about religion
it's not about politics Democrats do it
too president obama has responded
similarly in other shootings and it's
not about religion as i said i'm not
anti thoughts and prayers by any means i
grew up in a very the very religious
deep south a baptist who went to a
Catholic school where we prayed at least
four times a day plus mass on Fridays
and church on Sundays sometimes twice so
spare me the anti religion tweet you can
keep them I won't even read them I don't
care
these god-fearing Christians were in
church
they were already praying thoughts and
prayers did not stop an oversight from
the justice system which enabled a guy
who attacked his stepson and assaulted
his wife from getting a gun thoughts and
prayers didn't stop a trouble person
from buying assault grade weapons that
took the lives of 26 people in an
instant okay so let me stop it there
again this is not what thoughts and
prayers are designed to do okay prayer
is not always designed to get you what
you want okay if people pray and they
got what they want God would be a
gumball machine that's not what
religious people believe yeah I assume
that Don prays I mean he says he does
but I'm not sure what he expects from
God again the problem of theodicy has
been one that religion has taken up time
and time again when it comes to human
evil the idea here is that human beings
have free will and we can pray that
those human beings don't use that free
will in the worst possible ways we can
pray that God protects us but God
sometimes says no right God sometimes
says no and this is one of the the
tragedies of human life is we don't
understand God's plan but let me talk
for a minute about what prayer actually
does so I'm gonna be completely sincere
here I have a difficult time praying I
pray three times a day it's not
something that I particularly enjoy
doing because in Judaism prayer can be
relatively formulaic when I say
relatively I mean very formulaic you say
the same prayer three times a day the
idea is that it's supposed to be almost
like a mantra it's supposed to provide
you a leaping off point to actually
think about God and think about your
relationship with him but prayer can be
very difficult unless you're actually
just sitting there concentrating and
what the purpose of prayer is so I've
really done a lot of thinking myself for
myself about what I think prayer does
particularly prayer in the aftermath of
tragedy I think that prayer does really
three things I think her does three
things first and reminds us that well it
is our job to strive to prevent evil
from succeeding each day God's plan is
not ours right half of Prayer is about
recognizing that your plan is not gods
you are not God right the point of
prayer is for you to say to God I
understand that you are the creator of
the universe and you are beyond my logic
I don't understand the ineffability of
God is a sacred notion in virtually all
major religions the idea that you are
not in control of the universe and the
suggestion that you can prevent all bad
things from happening with prayer that's
not what prayer is for that's why
religious people get upset when they
hear things like what Don Lemon is
saying because he's misconstruing what
prayers for no one who believes in
prayer believes that prayer is going to
prevent a Justice Department oversight
no one believes that that's what prayer
is designed to do one of the things
prayer is designed to do is remind us
not to be utopian not to believe that we
can stop every tragedy from happening
not to believe that there's any power in
the universe that is capable of
implementing our will specifically and
making it the rule for everyone that's
not prayers designed to do the reverse
it's designed to remind us not to be
utopians and in what Karl Popper would
call a sort of utopian negative model
right that would help us run roughshod
over the rights of other people because
remember half of what Don Lemon is
saying here about you know we need to
change the law would wreck it every
every law is an imposition on somebody
so who are you whose rights are you
imposing on prayer reminds us that you
don't actually get to do that all the
time right that utopia is not something
that you can aim for while violating the
rights of others because God in the end
is the actual judge right when somebody
dies Jews say Barack died on emmett
right barrels died on ms that's that's
what Jews say what that means is blessed
is the true judge meaning that I don't
get to make the call as to whether
something that just happened is
according to God's plan only God can
make that call and I may not understand
it and I can mourn it I mean we cry at
funerals and we're not crying because we
question God's justice
we're crying because it's sad right we
may not we may not understand in the
same way that children cry when their
parents are trying to implement justice
the kids don't understand we don't
understand there's no way for us to
understand that's what faith is
okay prayer also helps us see the value
in other human beings and convey that we
understand that value to other human
beings
now we're atheists where we religious
people see prayer as nothing but empty
verbiage it doesn't accomplish anything
how many people have been bettered by
communities that pray right prayer takes
place in communal settings not just
individual prayer I think that
individual prayer is valuable but
Judaism believes and I believe so does
Christianity that communal prayer is
more valuable than individual prayer
that individual prayer is useful but
you're supposed to get together in a
community because the idea is that that
community draws other people in how many
bad people how many would-be shooters
have been converted by going to places
like churches and praying with others a
lot how many evil people have been drawn
into the Nexus of a community that prays
and sees the value of other individuals
before God that has prevented that
action you never see it you never see it
because you only see the bad stuff
remember with with that with the
Charleston South Carolina shooter there
is
there's a report that came out shortly
afterward I'll have to look it up where
this this piece of garbage white
supremacist who murdered a bunch of
people in church he said he had trouble
pulling the trigger because when he went
in there there were all of these black
people who are really nice to him and
were praying with him right he was evil
enough that he was able to overcome that
drop there are a lot of people who
aren't there are a lot of people who are
turned away from dark paths by
communities that pray together and value
one another prayer is valuable in a
communal setting okay but neither of
these things has to do with what the
left believes the left believes the only
thing that is actually impactful in in
the world is not our communities
releasing reaching out to each other the
soft kind of touches that stuff doesn't
work right they don't believe that us
accepting a godly justice is a
worthwhile thing we should fight against
that right we should we should be like
Ahab fighting against God trying to stab
through the pasteboard masks of Moby
Dick that's what we should be doing
every day and there's something to the
notion of struggling with God I mean
Judaism believes that you know that
struggle is is ongoing but the idea in
the end is that God is right and you're
wrong right but in any case that does
not that's not an excuse for inaction
when action is called for but here is
the problem right prayer obviously
supposed to motivate you to go out and
do better things it's motivate you to do
better I suppose be fuel in your gas
tank but the left assumes that if I
disagree with the direction you're
steering the car I don't have fuel in
the gas tank the prayer didn't put fuel
in my gas tank prayer was useless
because I don't agree that you ought to
be aiming the car at gun control well I
don't believe you should be aiming the
car gun control because I don't think
that the additional laws that you've
been proposing are useful by the way I
have said when I think an additional law
might be useful or at least called for
after Las Vegas I said that I would I
would not vote against a law that
prevented the the sale of bumped stocks
and so it's not like I'm against ever
I'm in favor of better enforcement
against people who have been mentally
ill and have been in mental hospitals
owning weapons hey Cruz pointed out and
he's right that there were like forty
thousand people illegally owned guns in
the United States and 44 of them are
prosecuted them there was forty thousand
people who tried to illegally buy guns
and Obama prosecuted 40 of them and we
need to implement the laws that they
already have on the books we don't need
new laws but that doesn't mean that my
prayers aren't ineffective it means that
I'm not praying for the same thing that
you are or the action to which I have
devoted myself is not the action you
choose but your suggestion that my
prayer is not accepted by you I'm not
praying to you and I don't care what you
think
of my prayer when I pray I'm talking to
God not to you because you're not God
and neither is government you know this
brings up a sort of broader conversation
about the role of religion in public
life I want to get to that in just one
second because there there's a big
controversy that's now broken out over
over a Hillsong pastor and abortion but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at naturebox listen we all
want to eat better when it comes to
snacks that usually means for you you're
hungry at the office and you grab a
candy bar and you shove it down your
face and now you're fat that's basically
what it means at the eye you got a bag
of potato chips and a bunch of garbage
snacks and you just need that quick
boost of energy because four o'clock
you're just trying get to five and so
you do that now you have to work it off
on the treadmill if you work it off at
all well that's why you need nature box
instead of garbage food nature box has
over 100 snacks that taste good and are
actually better for you they're very
popular around the office favorites
around the office include the vanilla
bean wafers apparently and they have a
dried mango as well and they have coffee
kettle popcorn that one is a particular
favorite around the office as well I get
favorites from everybody else in the
office because not all the naturebox
snacks are kosher but these ones are
very popular around the office and I've
been told they are just delicious you're
sure to find your new snack obsession
over at nature boxing right now they're
offering my fans 50% off your first
order when you go to naturebox
commenting and that's naturebox common
for 50% off your first order and they
rotate these snacks all the time the
list is really really long of these
snacks and they are all apparently
really delicious
and they've like almond butter and they
have oatmeal and they have salt and
vinegar veggie chips you know all the
things that you'd want to snack on
that's what they do in nature box common
for 50% off your first order you're
going to snack at the office we know you
are don't get bat eat healthy and eat
delicious you don't have to sit there
and be sad just because you're sitting
there eating lima beans from the freezer
can actually get a good snack that
tastes good and is good for you
naturebox calm
for 50% off your first order okay so
this brings up a broader critique of the
role of religion so it's really funny
the left says prayers are good but only
if they are directed in our direction
now what people who are conservative
believe conservative religious people is
that the direction for the prayer is
basically toward God which means that
you actually have to look at what God's
agenda is in particular circumstances
God is not just something out there
that is non discoverable the Bible is
pretty clear about this right in
Deuteronomy Moses specifically says it
is not in heaven where you can't
understand it it's down here got the
whole purpose of having a revelation is
that you understand things now not
everyone has to believe in revelation
you don't have to believe in revelation
right you can be skeptical of Revelation
but if you say you believe in revelation
at the very least you should be adherent
to the revelation and if you say you're
a Bible believing person you should at
least believe in the Bible in the same
way that if you you know believe in
global warming you should at least
believe in global warming right whatever
you're gonna believe in believe in it
otherwise you're a liar well Hillsong
there's a megachurch pastor I don't know
Hillsong particularly well but there's a
guy named Carl Lentz apparently who's
quite popular and dresses in very odd
fashion and he was on the view wearing
glasses that he apparently got from a
forever 21 and a medallion that I don't
know what it represents but he looks
like he looks kind of like Marky Mark
from 1991 in any case Carl Lentz is very
popular pastor maybe he's great I don't
know but what he said here was not great
right on the view
I say he's on the view and he has asked
about abortion saying abortion is sinful
and here is his answer this is where
religion does fail okay religion doesn't
fail just because you don't support gun
control religion does fail if your Bible
says abortion is bad and then you give
this answer and it makes so it's not a
sin in your church to have an abortion
that's kind of conversation we would
have finding out your story where you're
from what you believe yeah I mean God's
the judge people have to live with their
own convictions and idly if I have to
tell you
[Applause]
that's such a that's such a broad
question to me I'm going I'm going
higher I want to sit with somebody and
say where do you believe not an
open-and-shut case with you some people
would say it is I think to me I'm trying
to teach people who Jesus is first find
out their story before I start picking
and choosing what I think is sin in your
life I'd like to know your name what non
sense
non sense sin is still sin that doesn't
mean that you have to be mean to people
who have sinned the whole purpose of
talking to people is to find out their
story but we have to start from a
certain basic premise yes
abortion is a sin of course abortion is
a sin and soft-pedaling it for the left
is not going to win you adherence or
converts soft-pedaling bad you know evil
is not going to stop peddling sin is not
going to draw more people to you it's
going to alienate more people from
religion because that's what gets people
to believe in this I'm spiritual but not
religious nonsense okay what do you do
you believe in the force congratulations
I mean can you move objects with your
mind I don't really care if your
spiritual but not religious the question
is what standards you uphold one of the
purposes of religion is to uphold a
higher standard because God has demands
of you not just you making demands of
God this guy got a lot of flack for it
as well he should at least a Krauss on
daily wire went after him she's invited
him to come into the daily wire offices
I'm sure we would all like to chat with
him and find out whether he actually
believes abortion is a sin or not okay
so I have some things I like and some
things that I hate then I want to talk
about today and it's gonna be a fun
things I like so you're gonna want to
stick around for that but you need to
subscribe to our website in order to
make that happen so for $9.99 a month
you can get your subscription to daily
wire calm that means they get the rest
of the Ben Shapiro show live on video it
means you get the rest of the Andrew
Klavan show live on video means you get
the rest of the Michael Noel's show live
on video it also means the yet to be
part of my mailbag and clave ins mailbag
also be sure to tune in to watch our
next episode of the conversation on
Tuesday November 14th at 5 p.m. Eastern
featuring the godless Michael Noel's and
if you are subscriber at the daily wire
then you can write in and send your
questions directly to Michael moles
we'll give you the world's worst answers
but they will probably be amusing the
conversation happening next Tuesday you
can only do it if you subscribe for
$9.99 a month for $99 a month you get
all of those things plus you get this
the very greatest in all beverage
containers the leftist tears hot or cold
vessel you will love it you will enjoy
it every bit of it is just phenomenal
you'll treasure it forever I get people
tweeting me all the time about how great
vessel is about how it restored their
loved ones to health after they were
suffering from from horrid diseases and
such I can't vouch for that because it's
not FDA approved but I can say that this
is a great beverage vessel for 99 bucks
you get that plus all of the other
effort mentioned things please subscribe
to our YouTube channel we have a bunch
of fun new videos that are coming out on
YouTube you won't know about them unless
you subscribe there and subscribe
over at SoundCloud or iTunes leave us a
review it always helps us with it helps
in the rankings and it helps people find
out about the show more broadly so leave
us a review we always appreciate it we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna go directly to things
I like in things I hate today I think so
things I like
there is a book that I read very quick
read by a guy named Alan Jacobs it's a
best-seller now called how to think and
it is sort of a short form review
essentially of ways that we are biased
and how best to conquer those biases I
love reading these kinds of books right
I've recommended Daniel Kahneman's book
before I've recommended the book flow
and the book drive I recommended a lot
of books about how it is that we have
cognitive biases and this book is about
that but it's also about why we
shouldn't despair of our ability to
overcome overcome these challenges to
bias the book again is how to think by
Ellen Jacobs like 150 pages very slim
very easy to read very conversational go
ahead and check it out it's a fun read
okay other things that I like so just
for fun today the Jon pod horse and I
like to go back and forth on movies John
is a the editor over at commentary
magazine and so not related to that I
decided that I was gonna start a hashtag
called accurate movie summaries kind of
taking the lead from the famous actor a
movie summary about The Wizard of Oz
which is three friends three friends
gather to kill which then then band
together to kill again or young girl
young girl kills which then bands
together with three friends to kill
again which is her the summary of Wizard
of Oz so the hashtag accurate movie
summaries was trending on Twitter and I
do love some of these so I have to read
you some of them noseless guy has a
healthy unhealthy obsession with a
teenage boy that would be Harry Potter
young boy who sees ghosts talks to a
ghost fair that's that's the entire
summary of The Sixth Sense for those who
have seen life skip the next 15 seconds
because yeah or who have not seen it
because it's a spoiler hey space octopus
kill some astronauts and all of humanity
but more importantly the astronauts this
one I love this ratatouille rodent cooks
dinner critics wowed fair this one I did
about It's a Wonderful Life Man
bankrupts bank and subprime mortgage
scheme is bailed out by well-meaning but
economically ignorant friends a cheating
woman sleeps with homeless guy on ship
ends up losing jewelry that's Titanic
old man grows beard convinced his little
girl he's Santa Claus
which is Miracle on 34th Street now this
one is mrs. Doubtfire it's pretty great
stressing unemployed man disguises
himself to stalk his estranged family
family eventually takes him back in this
one I think is my favorite is see if he
gets the movie man gets stuck on an
island after plane crash wife moves on
with another man man moves on with
volleyball man cast away and then of
course this one self-righteous juror
cuddles more sober-minded colleagues
into releasing a patricidal murderer
that of course is 12 Angry Men
I also there are a bunch of them this
one is pretty great and it's you've
heard this one before I'm sure teenager
destroys military installation at the
behest of an elderly religious zealot
with the aid of a wanted criminal
killing millions of active military
service members star wars that is in
indeed III will say I like this one too
this one a little harder a professor
prevents Hitler from opening a historic
Jewish artifact that would have killed
Hitler and ended World War two that's
Indiana Jones and Raiders of the Lost
Ark because think about it for a second
guys think about it if he just lets
Hitler get the actual Lost Ark and
Hitler opens that sucker then Hitler
dies at the end of Indiana Jones the
whole thing is the giant misdirect right
he's chasing the are chasing the are
chasing the Ark and then it turns out
the Ark is his friend okay that time for
a quick thing that I hate so there are a
lot of things that are out there to hate
today but I choose John Kerry John Kerry
John Kerry former Secretary of State and
he says it's just it's Donald Trump's
fault the North Korea is seeking a
nuclear weapon I was just out water
sporting in my art John Kerry go I think
what the president needs to do is make
sure that he's not feeding into North
Korea's fear of regime change or of you
know a unilateral attack or otherwise
and I think the rhetoric to date has
frankly stepped over the line with
respect to the messages that are being
sent it's given North Korea reason to
say hey we need a bomb because we don't
have a bomb we're gonna you know not be
able to protect ourselves and they'll
come after us okay so no okay the idea
that you're meeting North Korea and
that they dad that's why they're
developing a bomb they started
developing the bomb under the auspices
of the Clinton ministration which signed
in North Korean framework in 1994 and
said the problem was ended they
continued it through the Bush
administration they accelerated under
the Obama administration say wouldn't it
have been nice if there'd been a
Secretary of State who could have done
something about that I'm just trying to
think of a separate oh wait he was
Secretary of State wasn't he my bad
also I I do have you know I'm gonna be
mean to John Kerry now but he deserves
it after slandering our troops in
Vietnam and spending his entire career
being awful at everything
then the man's face in a stage of full
structural collapse it's like a mudslide
in the Hollywood Hills at this point and
a certain point you do too much Botox
and you start to look like like larch I
mean it pretty amazing okay any case
deconstructing the culture will do for
five seconds here so well first I do
want to mention that there's a new
report from The New Yorker about Harvey
Weinstein and his and how he was
attempting to cover up his sexual
assault and sexual harassment Ronan
Farrow released a blockbuster expose
multiple women have accused him of one
scene of rape and now apparently
Weinstein had these extensive efforts to
silence people he hired private
investigators and expose to suppress
allegations they hired Kroll one of the
world's largest corporate Intel
companies and black cube an enterprise
run by former officers of Mossad and
they they used false identities to meet
with Rose McGowan who eventually
publicly accused once univ rape to
extract information from her he directed
efforts to kill accusation stories from
the New York Times and New York Magazine
and he used his lawyer David Boies lead
his lead his effort to prevent the New
York Times from from doing any of these
reports David Bowie boys as you remember
was an attorney who represented gore in
the bush-gore presidential election saga
he had agents posing as advocates for
women he had front companies to cover
his operations he hired investigative
journalists to interview and collect
informations from the accusers so he's
actually hiring the chief contents offer
for officer from the National Enquirer
okay this is pretty horrific stuff and
it demonstrates again how Hollywood is
able to manipulate the news from behind
the scenes and even manipulate some DC
players okay so should we save the rest
of deconstructing the culture for next
week are we out of time we're out of
time so we'll have to save some
deconstructing culture for next week I
was going to do post Malone but we'll
have to save that for next to
and remind me and we'll do it next week
as well okay so we'll be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest news I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]